I'm Alan Verret I'm the tech lead for
the Android support library
I'm Armas and I'm software engineer on
Android support library hi and I'm Kathy
Tam the technical program manager for
the support library and today we're
gonna be talking about what is new in
the latest version of the android
support library as well as some new
things that you can look forward to in
the future and on this beautiful spring
day in Mountain View California we're
gonna start with a little bit of spring
cleaning we're gonna talk about some
technical debt that has been building up
in the support library so we're on
Twitter we're on Stack Overflow
we're on reddit maybe we're on reddit a
little bit too much but we noticed some
basic aspects of the support library
there were a little bit let's say messy
so we've reached out and spoken with
developers and try to find out some ways
that we can improve the basics of
support library and lay a strong
foundation for future work and we got a
lot of good feedback some very
high-level some very specific we know
about the issues with showing and hiding
the I mean but we drilled down to the
basics we got feedback on our maven
packaging so our artifact and package
names our Java packages have become a
little bit confusing as support library
has aged and in general we built up a
lot of technical debt so like last year
we're going to talk about what's old in
the android support library first so we
started in 2011 with support v4 and as
I'm sure everyone here knows that
provided backward compatibility for
devices running SDK for the first public
release of Android and we grew we gained
libraries for watched components car
components testing support for SDK 13
for 11 so we have a lot more than just
backwards compatibility now but we still
got these artifact names so we've got
support v4 everyone's familiar with that
support V 13 who knows what's in support
V 13
uh literally less than 10 people Armas
knows so support v13 at this moment
contains nothing because our minimum SDK
for everything is 14 V 13 just redirects
to V 4 V 4 actually redirects to a bunch
of other components these are both just
umbrella artifacts on maven so why do we
have all of these weird versioning names
in our maven artifacts and in our
package names well they're kind of hard
to change but these are confusing it's
not a great place to start if you're new
to Android development we also have a
lot of versions of all of these
libraries so recommendation is something
that was added back in 23 and hasn't
changed a lot since then so we have 30
versions of basically the exact same
library and what does the versioning
scheme mean here well 24 means it was
released when at Google i/o when SDK 24
came out we had an alpha one
corresponding with the pub first public
release DP 1 alpha 2 4 DP 2 beta 1 4 DP
3 but it doesn't make a lot of sense for
us to be corresponding to just the i/o
releases wouldn't it be great if we had
alpha and beta releases for every
version of the support library and
wouldn't it be great if we didn't have
to do that for every single library even
if it hadn't changed so you may have
seen like a 2400 that should have had a
little bit more testing maybe there
should have been a beta 2 there or maybe
you pulled in 25.4 and found some bugs
that really should have been an alpha so
we've been doing a lot better about
testing but wouldn't it be great if our
dot 0 releases weren't still alpha
quality so today we're gonna focus on
fixing how we structure our libraries
how we handle changes to them and how we
ship them to developers and we're using
this to form the foundation for jetpack
and we're calling it Android extension
libraries or Android X for short
so welcome to what's new in Android X
we'll be talking about foundational
features new feature foundational
changes new features and what you can
expect from us in the future first
though I'd like to talk about the
relationship between jetpack which
everyone may remember from the keynote
and Android X so jetpack is a set of
guidance recommended libraries and tools
and this is going to teach you how to
create good apps
this may include libraries that are in
Android X this may eventually include
libraries that aren't in Android X and
as guidance changes and evolves you may
see that some things in Android X become
deprecated and are no longer part of the
jetpack recommendations also it's got
this cute logo and red X on the other
hand is the libraries themselves these
are guarantee is about versioning API
surface dependency structure and we do
not have a cute logo so let's dive into
details what exactly is going to be
changing we're going to have logical
smaller more scoped artifacts so for
example if you're looking for a
viewpager it's going to be in the
viewpager artifact rather than support
v4 you may remember the support v4 split
that we did last year where we split out
two core UI and a number of other
artifacts we've done that again this
year so we have smaller artifacts if you
need view pager you just pull in view
pager you don't pull in a bunch of other
widgets that you may not need this is of
course non-breaking like the split that
we did last year
so if you pull in support v4 you still
get all of that umbrella of libraries if
you pull in core UI you still get view
pager and everything else but you also
have the option of just pulling in
exactly what you need so here's the
split of the libraries this is just a
sample so you'll see that support compat
has been broken down into collections
this is a pure Java library it's a jar
instead of an aar it has no resources
you can use it with host tests because
it doesn't have any dependencies on the
Android package core is the backwards
compatibility that you're used to from
support v4 you're going to see less of
the compat moniker in the future as
support our as Android X is becoming the
primary development surface for a lot of
framework api's so here you can see if
you need swipe refresh layout you pull
in exactly that you don't get anything
that you didn't need we're also moving
to versioning that makes more sense so
instead of monolithic releases that are
tied to Google i/o we're going to reset
from 28 to 100 and the major version
number now actually means something so
previously we would break binary
compatibility on any minor version bump
and if you're using a library that
depends on a specific version of support
library this can be really problematic
you may not even find out until runtime
that some methods signature that a
library depends on has changed our moved
to strict semantic versioning with
Android X means that you can always
expect the major version number to
indicate binary compatibility anything
in a 1.4 version of the library anything
with a 1.4 dependency on a library for
example would be compatible with 1.5 1.6
all the way up until 2.0 we're also
going to be doing per artifact
versioning and release so instead of a
monolithic release if we have a bug fix
for recycler view we release a dot one
of just the recycler view library you
only have to pull in one new artifact
and if you don't need it you don't have
to pull it in so it's going to be very
low effort on the part of the developer
alright and we want to make it easy to
know what's inside each artifact so as I
mentioned our main artifacts are now
finer scoped they correspond to features
instead of very broad swaths of for
example all of support v4 we have a
consistent scheme of Android X teacher
dot package and class according to layer
and functionality and our mavin mavin
naming scheme reflects this so our group
IDs are going to be Android X teacher
this will correspond directly to the
Java package the artifact ID will be the
feature and if there is a sub feature
for example recycler review selection
you will see Android X dot recycler view
: recycler view - selection you also
noticed that we've moved
of the v7v for explicit SDK require
explicit backwards compatibility or
explicit compiled SDK requirements so
our min SDK requirement is built in to
the Android manifests for these
libraries and we also make heavy use of
the requires API annotation so you may
run into methods that require may return
a new object so you may see something
that returns compat something that
returns the actual object and you can
call that if you're on a newer platform
all right so let's step into an example
of that here's an example of some
libraries that you may already be using
we're unifying everything under the
Android X top-level package so
everything that was in combat Android
support is now an Android extension
library everything from Android arch is
now an Android extension library for the
most part we're preserving the names but
you'll see some simplifications
so Android arch persistence room for
example is now just room when you're
looking for room you can find it very
quickly let's tick down on support
compat and card uv7 specifically and
take a look at some of the classes so
build compat has moved from a explicit
v4 support to android core OS build
compat and in the future you'll actually
see a lot less of the compat suffix on
classes card vb7 is now just card u dot
which 'its and the classes card view
you'll find other supporting classes in
card view dot util etc so hopefully this
isn't too shocking I think this is a
very long awaited refactoring that we've
really been wanting to do for a long
time and you might be wondering how do I
get that so we'll hand over to Armas
he's gonna walk you through what it
looks like to migrate your application
hello there
all right thanks Alan so I will walk you
guys through our migration story and how
you want to get to the Android X library
usage so first things first if you're
using Android studio we will be
providing an automated tool for
migrating over it's this tool is
available starting Android studio 3.2
canary 14 that shipped yesterday
this automated tool sodomy the tool will
be in the existing refactor menu that
you probably hopefully love and where we
add it as we added a new option that's
called refactor to Android X and this
single click will go and identify all
the usages of android support library
alt classes and it will pull them up in
the review pane where you're going to be
able to see what has changed and what
we're about to migrate for you and after
review you click do a refactor and we'll
go ahead and refactor and what this will
handle it will go handle your source
code including your counseling classes
it will handle simple bill scripts
unless you have something more complex
in which case we're gonna publish maps
of old artifact to the new artifact so
you can do the migration in the slightly
more manual way now migration will also
handle resources such as your layout
files and then finally but not least
what you're gonna have is we're gonna
handle migration of binary dependencies
or ARS and jars we know that many of you
use third-party libraries that depend on
support library and there could be glide
or many other libraries so to help you
with that
we've wrote a tool called jet afire and
this tool performs binary translation
using ASM which jumps into the jar and
goes and rewrites all the uses of the
old or library to become the new support
library this handles code inside of the
jar ID handles XML resources it even
handles ProGuard files we will also
publish a standalone jar that you can
run manually if you'd like to have
checked in versions of these pre bills
that you depend on and now let's jump to
the laptop where I'm gonna give you a
demo of how this tool works and
hopefully the demo works beautifully
of course here we go alright let's jump
to the laptop right ah so here you're
looking at the Topeka Android app it's
available on Google samples github page
it's nothing super amazing this is just
using standard components and showing
examples of how it works as you see in
the Android emulator I'm running this
app it works you can click on things but
now what we gonna do we're gonna jump
into the refactor menu hit the refactor
to Android X what this is gonna do is
gonna go jump in and search through all
the uses of all the old support library
classes in both XML Java and in all the
other places that we migrate for you and
after it's done searching for it's gonna
present all the things that it will
suggest for you to migrate and in this
case I'm looking at the specific sign-in
fragment class and you can see there's a
bunch of uses of support library and
what is gonna happen when I hit do
refactor it will go and rewrite all of
these in including build script files
and everything and of course Gradle
needs to go and sync again now because
we just changed all of it dependencies
and the clasp apps need to be reloaded
so now that's where you twiddle your
thumbs a little bit and wait for us to
do two doubts to do its thing and now we
are using new stuff and now when I hit
build and install hopefully in a few
seconds at home you probably would go
grab a coffee but here we can't do that
on the stage but it will go and install
it on emulator any moment now it will
stall a little bit longer by saying
other words tada and now you see this is
a new app is this the same app using a
brand new Android X library and
migration was fairly painless so let's
jump back to the slides
alright of course some of you are not
using Android studio and for you for
those people we will be providing a
giant CSV file that has a mapping of old
class to the new class and that in
addition to the standalone jeddah fire
tool you should be able to hook up
together in your build system and your
IDE to do the migration manually if if
you're not using studio so in summary we
are providing these tools in Android
studio 3.2 canary 14 and Jetta fires
already in Google maven however this is
coming in really hot even the demo that
I was using is actually not using canary
14 is using for nearly 15 that's
shipping next week because we found bugs
when we're trying to do the demo so
please wait until canary 15 to start
using this but when you do in canary 15
please take a look at it try to migrate
your projects and if you find any issues
with it please file bugs
we're very you know we want this to make
it as easy as possible and want you to
migrate and start using all the new
stuff however you know migration takes
time so we will still ship Android
support library 28.0 alongside of
Android X however note that this is the
last feature release so this is kind of
like a little bit of a timeline for you
to kind of move forward and if you want
to know a little bit more of how this
works behind the scenes inside of
Android studio there will be a talk
about Android build build system at 6:30
in in this room so hopefully you can go
and take a look at that so it's not all
about refactoring we also added new
features and I'm gonna talk you walk you
through some of these so the first
feature I want to talk about is the
recycler view selection and this is a
library that will allow you to handle
item selection a lot easier it will help
you handle motion events and touch
events and convert them into selection
in the recycler view this is a fairly
flexible library where allows for custom
layout managers and a lot of custom
actions that you can do with so let's
jump through and see how you use it as
you can imagine you add a new dependency
to your build our Gradle file and the
important thing to note here is that we
are using the new Android X our
fact this is the same stuff that Alan
was talking about so for the set up what
you need to do is you want to create a
new layout a new adapter and the adapter
the important thing is that it uses
stable IDs we're using a stock grid
layout manager and we set both of these
on the recycler view there is no
selection code just yet we're just doing
the basic recycling we set up the
adapter as I said again nothing super
exciting the only important thing here
is that we're doing stable IDs and this
allows for a consistent mapping from ID
to the item and then next when we jump
back to the activity we stopped setup
selections library sees key provider and
this in conjunction the stable IDs will
allow for a quick mapping between the
IDs and the items that will handle the
selection by the selection library and
now what we need to setup is the
selection tracker which actually is the
actual machinery behind the scenes and
we pass in recyclerview the key provider
both of these that we just created and
in my details look up and my detailed
lookup is actually a fairly simple class
you need to overwrite only one method
and then the sight of that one you
retain it returned item details and that
returns the position and the selection
key for the item that is for the given
motion event and finally recyclerview
has no default selection mechanism so
what you have to do is you have to
handle it or non bind so there you might
want to change the background of the
view or you can use it by setting
activated state and to get activated
state working you use background for the
view and that background is a selectable
drawable that has an activated state
which will allow to indicate to user
that item has been selected so this is a
basics this library has a lot more you
can set up band selection you can add
custom selection areas you can have
items that are not square you can have
circular handling and stuff like that
there's a lot of stuff you can do to
this library and an important part of
this slide that's my dog Jack all right
another thing that we added to recycle
view is a list
and what does him does for you is is it
helps you to work the recycler views
that change the content over time so
what you all you need to do is submit
the new list we run a diff utils tool
behind the scenes for you on the
background thread and then we run the
animations based on how the list is
changed and this is all a handle be a
very simple API and I'm gonna walk you
through it so what you need to do is you
create a difficult back in difficult
back has to implement two methods first
one make sure that the items are the
same where you compare the item IDs and
the second one you want to check that
that content is the same where you do a
deeper comparison we're essentially
equals in Java and in there if there is
a change we will know how to crossfade
your item from one to the next and then
the adapter what you need to do in our
bind you just call get item and you do
your regular binding and then that's
that's all you need to do to get the
animation working and then a highly
complex code in the activity you call
submit list of your list and that's it
you're done note this works really well
with live data and rx
Eric's Java observables so if you need
to do a lady more advanced adapter we
also have a base adapter called a single
is differ so if you need to do that just
go and look into that if you like to
know more about list adapter and similar
utilities see
managing infinite lists the recyclerview
and paging talk on Thursday at 2:30
right so another thing that we added is
Android extra WebKit library and what
allows you to do is to get the api's
that we've added in in webview on the
older versions in a backwards compatible
way this library works on API 21 and
newer where we introduced the updatable
webview through a Play Store so you take
an example of Safe Browsing API that we
added in API 27 this prevents loading of
malicious URLs in the webview inside of
your application and previously you
could only use it on API 27 in newer but
now you're gonna be able to use it on
older devices so similarly we're gonna
add a Gradle dependency to get this
working again
looking at the Android X artifacts
hopefully you got this by now and then
we check if feature is available and if
it is we start say browsing it's as
simple as that and you get the safer
experience of safe browsing starting
with API 21 and newer and similarly many
other API is that we added since API 21
now will become backwards compatible
available to your application so
hopefully you'll check this out
so another library that we've renamed is
custom tabs this library became Android
Browser this doesn't actually change the
functionality it will continue to work
the Oly browsers that already implement
this so Chrome Firefox and Samsung
Internet all of them implement this and
if you're using it they will continue to
work the cool thing about this we added
a new feature inside of the library
which is called browser actions and what
allows you to do is is allows you to
hook into the context menu off the
browser so for example now your reddit
app can finally open links in incognito
tab which can be very handy it works in
Chrome starting Rome 66 and it will
start working in other browsers when
they adopted so again to use this it's
fairly simple you set up in intense
pending intents for your browser a
browser browser action items and this is
all this is optional if you don't need
any extra ones in your dialog we don't
have you can skip this part
another optional part you setup is
[Music]
browser action tracking so what this
allows you to do is you can see what
user ended up selecting inside of the
dialog and then finally you just fire up
the browser action dialog and then you
end up with something like this and you
can do you know additional actions for
yourself or you can hook into the
browser whereas previously you weren't
able to do this via simple attempts
because browsers weren't interested in
exposing a lot of this functionality
directly another library that I'm gonna
talk about is he Frater he stands for
high efficiency image format and we
introduced this support to the platform
for Heath in Android P an alongside
we're launching this library that allows
you to take byte buffers
surfaces and bitmaps and write them to
the file currently it is only API 28 and
newer they're not super useful but we
are working on a backboard that it will
allow you to use it on older versions
again usage is very simple you fire up
the Builder to create a new chief writer
object in there you can set up a bunch
of options like image size or quality
you hit build and once you have it you
start you start writing to it you put in
bet maps and once you're ready and
you're done then you want to write it
out to disk you call stop to the timeout
and the timeout can be 0 if you want to
have an indefinite wait an important
part here is you want to do this work on
the off of the wife read because you're
gonna be doing disk and to tell you a
little bit more about other features in
Android X I invite Kathy thanks thanks
Armas so the next feature I want to talk
about that we added in Android exists a
feature called slices slice this is a
feature that allows you to display
content outside of your app so the goal
here is to have one reusable API that
both the system and other apps can
request content from your app today we
have already integrated with search I'll
go is to look into integration with
notification long press or even
homescreen in the future so what does
this content that you get to present
this content is both templated and
interactive its templated so that when
you have kind of live content you can
display it in a rich and flexible layout
and the good content is interactive
because we allow you to add existing
controls like widgets extruding were
just like sliders toggles or scroll
Europe so that together you can have
live data with inline actions or even
deep links into your app
you can also choose to integrate your
slices with search so a user can see
display app content by searching your
app name or even general terms that
you've registered this is a win-win for
both users and the apps because users
can get rich live data immediately and
for app your app to reach millions of
users because this is implemented in
Android X it is usable immediately up to
API 19 so let's take a look at how you
can use it so as you would expect we
have to first import the library since
three libraries in a import and here we
importing from Android X the first is
the sliced builders that includes
methods to build content in a template
format the NICS library is the slice
view this contains method two so that
you can present the content and the last
library to import is slices core that
contains methods for permissions so to
build a slice you have to define a slice
implement the slice and handles by
section let's take a look at how we can
do it so the first thing we need to do
is to let the system or other apps know
that you have slices to provide so you
do that by implementing your slice
provider so you register your flights
provider in your Android not manifest
file next you have to extend from the
slice provider and implement your slice
provider you can have multiple slices
for your app so this is where the
business logic happens when when a
platform or another app once you call
get your slices you get a call on unbind
slice there you get a you get a call
with the URI of the slice being
requested and you you have to return
your slicing immediately so any Content
that needs to be loaded should be kicked
off and you would return it and don't
slice so let's take a deeper look and
we're gonna construct the slice here
and with we get able to construct it
with several builded classes including
broke builder brick road builder and
list builder so let's take a look so
here we go use the list builder to add a
very simple header the header contains a
title and
subtitle and you see the method add
header that adds the header then to
build on top of it we can use the grid
road builder first we get to the latest
weather information and then we can loop
through it adding a cell to the grid
road builder and by just calling ed grid
row at the bottom we append the rest of
the slice to the header so what will you
get here is that based on screen real
estate if it is small who show us
shortcuts slice the short cut slice pick
up an image from your slice so because
we have the weather image we'll pick
that up but if you didn't have an image
will show your app icon and then if the
screaming us they only allow for a small
slice it will be the head of that show
and finally if it has enough space we
will show the full slice so to learn
more about slices there was a talk this
morning that you can review but I only
just covered very basic of it and you
can learn more about templates
permission and integrating research in
the other talk and you can also meet the
team at the office hour 10:00 tomorrow
morning at 10:30 so the next topic I
want to talk about is a material
component we launched material
components for Android back in support
library 2800 alpha-1 in march and we
have also launched it for Android X
yesterday so as you know material
theming is a scientist support great
user experience we have made a lot of
improvement since oh so one of the first
thing we've done as part of the Android
X refactoring is that instead of being
an Android to support that design
they've been we've moved it to calm down
Android calmed our Google Android got
material we've done a lot of extensive
usability study on how to make these
widgets work well for you so we've made
them more usable and accessible and
we've updated styling so that you can
better express your brand and include a
new UI components so let's take a look
so here's an overview of the theming
capability on your right there is a very
brand agnostic baseline and on your left
there is the Google branded all the
components can pull from the theme so
that it makes it
easy for you to have app white teaming
let's walk through some of this in code
as you would expect we'll have to import
the library here note that it is coming
from combo Google Android of material
and I need to use our baseline theme you
define a kind of set the theme to be
material components not light this is
the kind of brand agnostic theme for you
to start with and then we provide a
whole bunch of attributes that you can
override so that your all the witches
within the app can pick up so here we
have defined primary color and text as
in theme dot XML and then on top of that
you can also define attributes for
different text styles with something
that comes out of box but you can also
define your own and although custom
widgets if you have custom widget that
uses these attributes it can also pick
up the theme so let's take a look at
some of the components that we've
updated first off is text field we've
done a lot of research and we have
improved the touch target making it more
easier for input and making it more
usable and accessible
we've also added new States to it which
includes focus State Aero State disabled
and text counter so we've kind of think
through all of it from the start to make
your life easier next up is button as
you can tell you can just use button the
way you use today by setting the
material component light theme will
automatically inflate this to the
material button that understand our
themes and pick up all the attributes
that you have set previously in your
theme file you can also use custom
attributes with these and then we also
providing two updated bars for you the
first is the bottom app bar the bottom
app bar allows you to add app actions
into your app and what we have done here
is that we have allowed you to we've
done research and saw that the phones
are bigger so we want to allow you to
position the your actions anywhere you
want along the bottom app bar so here we
have a fab that is centered and then can
be
animated to be right aligned the other
bottom car that we have updated is the
bottom navigation bar so just to clarify
that bottom app bars for actions and the
bottom navigation bar is for different
section within your app we do not
recommend and make mixing these
metaphors so you but we provide both for
you to choose from so they can build
yeah so pulling all of this together is
the material card view that is a wrapper
on the existing card view in the support
library or Android X which simplify how
this was built so that has less
elevation and shadow and it also pulls
from the theme in color so here you can
see all the elements coming together
with the text button and all of that in
the material card view with this
component you will have to define using
material card view explicitly we're
looking to see whether we can integrate
it as well so with that you can learn
more about this and in stage 8 at 4:30
on how to encourage what's new with
material design in your code base and
Android X is only one part of jetpack so
jetpack is a set of components tools and
guardians to help you great go great
Android apps quickly and easily so we're
at this talk but we're four more talks
to look for you to learn more about
jetpack so with that thank you Eleonora
miss and i will be hanging out at the
android 10 right over there
[Music]